-Every time we talk, I just love
hearing stories about you.
I love your opinion on
different things.
And I thought we could maybe do
something different this time.
I wanted to play a game with you
called "Wheel of Opinions."
Are you down with this?
-I'm so ready.
I'm so excited to play a game.
-Yeah. I love it.
Okay, here we go.
Let's -- I want your opinion.
Let's see what happening.
[ Beeping ]
Ooh!
Alright, this is it.
I want to hear your opinion.
Throw pillows --
what do you think?
-Too many to get comfortable.
-Yes.
-You can never use
one throw pillow
to really get comfortable
on a couch.
You know, being short,
there's so much space
between me and the back,
I need about
four of those throw pillows
in order to look like an adult.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, that's interesting.
Okay, here we go.
Let's try another weird opinion.
What's your opinion on...
Oh. Bite or lick your ice cream?
-Okay, I say both.
You start with a lick.
You end up when you get down to
the cone with a bite.
-Yeah, that's correct,
how you do it!
I forgot you do bite the cone.
You have to bite the cone.
-Have to bite the cone
to get to the ice cream
that has melted
into the core of the cone.
-Yes, that is a reward.
I totally forgot about that.
Alright, let's do one more here.
Here we go.
Final topic is...
[ Beeping ]
Well, this is going to be
controversial.
Henry, this is
better BTS song --
"Butter," their new song,
or "Dynamite"?
-Okay, okay, so, I like when
all of them sing together.
And they sound really good.
There are about 150 of them.
They -- Really.
And they make the sound of
butter delicious.
So I'm going to go with
"Dynamite."
-[ Laughs ]
That's what I'm talking about.
That's why we love you.
Henry Winkler, everybody!
"Monsters at Work" premieres
July 7th on Disney+.